>> Um, can India become a superpower?
I think yes, certainly, yes.
I think India has all the -- all the ingredients,
the raw ingredients
to become a superpower.
Whether it happens in ten years or in 15 years,
remains to see.
It has the size, the geographic size as well
as the economic so -- and,
but I think we need to India is important
superpower it wants to be, it
has the power to react very well [INAUDIBLE]
and has potential to have
good impact around the world.
What [INAUDIBLE] at least the current India
is based on the [INAUDIBLE]
India wants to become empowered base of peace
and prosperity.
And culture that [INAUDIBLE] superpower.
Three years, and so it has been revealed to
become a power superpower,
30, 40 years or even less but the world would
like to see India become
a superpower, a real base that is possible
here [INAUDIBLE]
Thank you.